pense qu'il faut se rendre compte que la
société a évolué depuis quelques
décennies et que maintenant nous sommes
à un niveau où quelque part tout le
monde n'accepte plus la violence à
l'encontre des animaux on n'accepte plus
de faire souffrir et de tuer un animal
pour le plaisir ça peut être le cas il
ya quelques siècles c'était même le cas
à l'encontre des humains on pouvait
accepter la souffrance contre des
humains pour le plaisir mais nous
n'acceptons plus cette violence et cette
souffrance contre les animaux la grande
question c'est que maintenant on a on
refuse celle là et elle se perpétue
toujours alors elle se perpétue déjà
bien sûr dans les abattoirs en france
puisque on tue 3 millions d'animaux
alors il faut savoir ce que ça veut dire
tu es 3 millions d'animaux dans les
abattoirs ce sont les égorger d'accord
on égorge 3 millions d'abattoirs dans
les animaux juste pour des plaisirs
gustatifs puisque c'est juste une
fonction de plaisir de manger de la
viande est là puisque le point de la
chasse nous intéresse la chasse de
loisirs c'est à les tuer et souvent
quand on tuer les animaux à la chasse on
les fait souffrir pour le plaisir donc
il ya un décalage énorme entre
l'évolution de la société qui de façon
pour l'instant encore très théorique
n'accepte plus le faire souffrir et de
tuer des animaux pour le plaisir et des
pratiques qui se perpétue et qui doit
bien sûr un jour
arrêter de continuer puisque ça ne
correspond plus je dirais à la morale de
la société et monsieur puel ont dit
qu'ils ne voient pas la souffrance il ne
voit pas la cruauté mais ne pas voir la
cruauté ne veut pas dire qu'il n'ya pas
de cruauté une voie de la cruauté le
jour où on se met g1 quand on prend le
point de vue de l'animal l'animal qui se
fait tirer dessus l'animal qui se fait
pour choix c'est pour chasser quand
c'est la chasse à courre sont des
animals qui sont en souffrance sont des
animaux des animaux terroriser et je
pense qu'il y a de la cruauté draps mais
à partir du moment où on se met du point
de vue de l'animal et je pense que ça
c'est le propre c'est le propre de
l'éthique de se mettre à la place de la
victime et appartements où on se met à
la place de la victime je pense que vous
pourrez tous est d'accord pour se dire
ne faisons pas souffrir et ne tuons pas
des animaux quand ce n'est pas
nécessaire
[Musique]